as far as gun control are things getting
better the way we're doing it or is it
getting worse because the numbers are
seeing way worse well let me give you
and then also with the numbers now
depending the way you look at the stats
guns are the number one thing that kills
children now it used to be car wrecks
guns if you include 17 year olds now
more kids die by guns than anything else
let me give you suicide all that yeah i
want to give you some stats on that
because we're going to take heat so i
want to just and this is something from
i listen to a guy who's very informed on
this i think his name is charlie kirk
kirk
and here's the interesting thing about
gun control that people should know
number one we're the only country in the
world that includes suicides okay
if you take suicides out of that
equation okay you just talking about
yeah and so i think it was last year
let's take the stats for last year you
have roughly eight thousand gun deaths
eighty percent of those gun deaths
eighty percent
set so of the 8 000
about 700 are actually um about 700 are
actually accidental discharges okay all
right about discharges okay they're
accidental discharges
so now you got about seven thousand of
those of that seven thousand of change
eighty percent of the deaths of the gun
deaths are inner city gang on gang
violence with handguns
that leaves about 2 000
homicides done which includes mass
shooters okay of the mass shooting about
i think it's three to four percent are
actually used they use a rifle okay so
it's very interesting to see these these
actual when you break these stats down
it's really interesting
of course it's a problem when fourth
graders getting shot when you say 45 000
deaths it's actually about 2 000
homicides and obviously nobody wants
this but that but then also something
but
you can paint that statistic but also to
say well let's take suicide out well no
that's a huge issue that's killing a lot
of people well so now we're dealing with
what we're dealing with the illness
thing and now and these shooters that
buffalo shooter and that [ __ ] this
kid they were showing signs of major
mental illness hold on the parkland
shooter made your size yeah but
was it alerted twice to this kid for
sure but the part the buffalo shooter
would be a case to me would be
monitoring freedom of speech and be
having this misinformation him being you
know compromised through a group so it's
not freedom of speech when you're making
direct freedom of speech you're making
direct threats but i'm sorry uncensoring
information yeah that that's that's
where that
argument comes from that kid well the
kids showed up i believe at school and i
have to check this i think it was him
who showed up to school for a week in a
complete hazmat suit correct wouldn't
take it that's correct now the students
and the teachers were like this kid is
crazy this kid something is very wrong
with this kid and they were all afraid
of him he would make really weird faces
there were signs
along the way that this kid was so
mentally ill he was going to do
something insane now
why is it
that a kid this
unhinged was able to buy [ __ ] uh two
ar-15s or whatever
on on his birthday and now we gotta in
the ammo but then guns in general forget
uh ar just means armor light thank you
guys for educating me armor light uh
armalite which is a company that yes m4s
and m60s but also that that kid you know
showed signs on social media was able to
find a group
to to compromise
and make them stream find a group
well it's gonna be easier to find a
group online if you like eating poo you
can find your group on
they found [ __ ]
forever oh they found me on there yeah
oh yeah i was like what i'm not doing i
don't want it in this group huh crazy
what'd you eat for breakfast